so i also saw a thing that was like that
you know after malcolm you're dying
after malcolm you were trying to get
into like more serious roles and it just
didn't like click yeah for you
you know it's funny i've done some
serious roles and i enjoy them the most
of anything i've ever done
um it was also more
when malcolm ended i started i got
signed to bmw to race cars and i said to
my agent's manager i said go look
this is what i want to do you know what
i mean i'm not trying to just do it as a
hobby like i want to be the best i can
be and like anything if you want to do
something the best you've got to put in
the time you need to get in the work
you know so i didn't think that it was
humanly possible to continue acting or
continuing the entertainment business
while doing the racing thing
so that's one thing like i'm so happy
sorry i'm so happy i went racing i love
every aspect of it now it's becoming a
part of my life again yeah and i think
in the in the biggest way it could but
i look back and i go
did i make a mistake leaving in the
height of my career like when i had
hundreds of offers i could have kept
going non-stop and i said no i don't i
don't want to where now i look back and
not that like i i
actively am pursuing trying to be an
actor but i go i wonder what my life
would have been if i stayed in that same
sense i look back and i go
thank goodness i left because i
appreciate life in general more but i've
started taking more in and i look back
at the success i had and i go
that was really cool you know what i'm
happy thank god
yeah i i think that you made the
healthier move definitely and i don't
think i ever would have been able to do
that yeah i think that i'm like just so
chronically
like attention-seeking
yeah and external validation oriented
that i would never be able to do that i
i feel like
and i i don't want you or anyone to take
this the wrong way i'm so much of a
happier person oh i bet having stepped
away not like being out of the line none
of that like just i don't know like
i don't know how to it's just a weird
it's a weird i've never been happier
like in my life like for some living in
arizona like something about arizona was
like i was like
content well
it's funny that it's funny that you say
that because like when i moved here i
realized as cheesy as this sound i
started looking up for the first time
like looking the clouds the weather the
mountains the long distance yeah rather
than like i don't know in l.a i just
kind of like kept my head down like like
literally
kept my head down all the time a lot of
sharks in l.a
i think people people want something
from you everywhere you go in l.a yeah
so maybe you're just kind of like
shrieking i don't know yeah i don't i
don't know i just i feel like this is
where i'm supposed to be i was told by
uh
i went to new orleans when i was like 11
and got my palm read
and the
the palm reader like told me all this
stuff and they go do you want to know
who you were in your past life
i was like sure
and he goes you were a judge defending
the native americans in the southwest
and he goes that's why you're drawn to
the southwest at the time i'd never been
west of the mississippi river i'm from
new jersey you know what i mean
like the southwest the minute i came
here i was like this is where i'm
supposed to be you know what i mean it's
weird so i don't fully believe in that
stuff but at the same time i go like i
think he was onto something yeah
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude